but there is a man on the phone line
right now who would know all about this
and he's about to spill every last thing
that Belichick just told the team
he's Dionne Louis here on the Rich Eisen
show from the Patriots right tianyu
you're ready to just tell us everything
verbatim correct hey Dianna I'm thrilled
that you're calling in here because I
really just love the way that you play
the game and your story of how you've
come back from leg injuries twice that
could have derailed your career where do
you see yourself right now Deon what
looking at your journey as you get set
to head to a second Super Bowl you
sitting back and just taking a look at
it sometimes and just marveling where
you've been oh no I'm just trying to
take it one day at a time just getting
ready for this game you know it's a big
game exciting game so just trying to
pull all my focus onto that and worry
about the other ones after we get a win
hopefully okay
so where where are you in preparation I
mean can you do least tell me what
meeting you just came out of something a
practice field like 10 minutes ago so
still going over some early now stuff
and just make sure we got everything
fine - and ready to go ok what what what
does I guess let's put it this way
what does McDaniels bring offensively to
this situation that apparently the Colts
might find out sooner rather than later
about what he brings to the table
how has he made you a better player I
know you're smart guy you know he does a
good job of gay guys in situations where
they can excel at so you know you
definitely a great play caller a great
job this year okay and in terms of your
your role in this offense how do you
view it Deon um changes from week to
week um some weeks I get the ball more
than others and some weeks I'm asked to
do different things than other week so
just got to just stick with the game
plan and whatever my role is I'm I'm
gonna do it to the best of my abilities
okay and where are you and your
preparation tickets wise family wise
what do you what do you got going on
right now for yourself uh uh I got three
people coming out about seven people
coming to the game so it would be a good
experience with my friends and family
good to be out there and enjoy them with
me so I'm definitely one of those spend
it with God with family members and
turns that I'm so close with who's with
me to mow my whole journey so
definitely gonna be good to have them
there with me and and I'll be enjoying
the time with my teammates aha now your
whole journey let's let's just hit that
a little bit here when when you got hurt
the first time when you were a Cleveland
Brown what did you think your career was
going at that point in time
Dioner I wasn't sure you know because it
was my third year and I haven't really
played much up into a point so I was
just kind of never really know what
wasn't happening I just try to stay as
bold as possible and I just kept working
and and now again we all know that you
suffered a knee injury and you've come
back from that from New England you were
drafted by the Eagles in 2017 and 2011
in the fifth round what was it like
being in the organization back then when
you got drafted by the team that you're
gonna try and prevent from winning the
Super Bowl in nine days it was great you
know just get used to be an NFL my first
few years you know how cut the deficit
here a great years for me um I didn't
have this type of production I wanted to
on the football field but nor as a
lender simple and it's going up until a
young adult you know it gave me great
experiences and almost things that
helped me go today who put their arm
around you and tried to guide you during
that process Dion Lewis a LeSean McCoy
you mind about right there my lookee
here Rhonda Bellinger as well and I was
the two guys I looked up to and it kind
of helped me figure out the league in
Sproles is not there yet right he came
after I got traded would you say it's
fair to say you you model your game
after his in a way I want to say that
you know he's definitely he's a great
player
I think we're different players as far
as our ability wise and he's a great
player
definitely looked at the way he catches
the back the ball on the back goes I
definitely study tape on that because
you know he's one of the better guys
that do that ever in the league about so
just had a gentleman from there so who
was your guy growing up that you would
say okay I want to get to the NFL one
day because I love this guy or he was
the guy that I modeled my game after was
that guy oh oh no I was a big fan of
LaDainian Tomlinson and Larry Sanders
you know those two degrees back of all
time and just had to learn as much as
possible always watching who to clip
they don't when I was younger just kind
of be a better player so uh I definitely
uh looked up to those two guys okay
have you met LT give her a cross pass
with him
um I haven't met no - yeah I haven't met
him yet I can take care of that I
definitely did in it I did interview
with him laughter and the playoffs I
believe okay after one of the games
around Medina so but I haven't met him a
person beyond Sanders
oh so you got the call you got the call
from prime gonna cook a couple of times
call the time okay now when you get the
call from prime you got to take that
call I know that oh yeah of course yeah
got to take that call that's there's one
of cause you can't decline right now now
you weren't named Dion because of that I
knew don't spell it the same way but I'm
just wondering is that possible I don't
know but it sounds good the plan
football so okay we got that all right
and so you were miked up for the AFC
Championship game by NFL Films were you
consciously aware that you were wearing
that mic during that game uh not really
I actually forget I actually forget
about it
because they tell you like unlike
Wednesday or Thursday that you're gonna
do it and before the game the white
relievers mind you so like I kind of
realize like halfway through the game
they off I might be cutting a little bit
too much but uh it's all it's all fun
okay and how is Brady doing Deion how's
he doing you know well you know he's Tom
you know working hard
I gotta be know what what is it like cuz
we all talked about him being a go what
is it like being around him what have
you picked up from him Dion Lewis what I
think you know his attention to detail
you know he comes in every day ready to
work I'm ready to prepare he's a great
leader he cares about about being great
and he and everything matters every
little thing matters to him he was one
to be perfect and I think that's um that
rubs off on the whole team well I played
with I've talked to people and worked
with people who played with Ray Lewis
and say they never wanted to disappoint
him that that was part of the pressure
that the pressure they always put on
themselves as a profession is one
professional is one thing but you never
want to be the one to miss an assignment
because you don't want to see that
person is that the same thing with you
and Brady oh yeah I think everybody on
team doesn't want to play anybody any of
our teammates you know because you know
course I'm was working together
season end you know we work hard
together and I don't think I think
everybody was hard for the man next to
him so we have a great great family here
teammate why then we play for each other
all right Dion so you're gonna you're
when do you head to Minnesota when do
you guys get on a plane
um maybe we leave on Monday Monday
morning I believe I'm not sure I think
it's Monday Monday well you gotta be it
uh we go you got to be at a podium
Monday now are you getting a podium you
get the podium online I'm not sure I how
I'm not sure about this year they
haven't told me anything yet I gotta
find out last minute be honest
everything last minute we can't take
steps backwards if you got a podium last
year you got a podium this year right
yeah hopefully okay cuz Gronk Gronk's
Reddy is Gronk a'practice is he looking
good too you know he's been here he's
been around in the building I already
know a situation I kind of try to worry
about myself and worry about what I have
to go to help us in other words do your
job that's what you say yeah okay all
right Deon I appreciate it and when we
come back you'll just stick around and
you'll give us the game plan when we
come back inside you'll see it will see
in Minnesota all right thank you okay
that's Dion Lewis for more Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Rich Eisen show
app